you
hello I'm Bob Stark and welcome to the
exciting world of CNC milling CNC stands
for computer numerically controlled you
have been given an assignment to create
a nameplate using a three axis CNC
milling machine in designing and
fabricating your nameplate
you will learn the basics of how to
program and use these machines and I
think you will also have a lot of fun
creating an original part that you can
keep for yourself or give away as a
present but before we get started let me
talk a little bit about safety inside
the machine shop before you walk into
the machine shop make sure you are not
wearing open face shoes or sandals next
make sure you're wearing these safety
glasses you will be using machines
capable of cutting steel so just imagine
what they could do to human flesh always
keep your hands away from all cutting
tools and never get close to them until
they have come to a complete stop be
familiar with where the emergency stop
buttons are located on the machine and
be prepared to engage it if necessary
should any accident occur no matter how
trivial it must be reported to either a
teaching assistant or the lab staff and
although it's obvious there is never any
fooling around inside the machine shop
never any running around or playing with
the compressed air guns that are used to
dust off the machines do not wear
loose-fitting clothes for it may get
entangled in mechanisms if your hair is
long pull it back and tie it in a rubber
band or wear a hairnet and always use
common sense in
the machine shop and although this is
not a safety issue per se machining is a
dirty job and we do not provide shop
aprons for our students so please do not
wear anything that you'd hate to get a
stain on now having said this let me
start off by assuming that you have
never had any experience inside the
machine shop environment to put a little
perspective on what you're about to
experience let me tell you that I went
to Brooklyn Technical High School in the
70s and at that time Brooklyn Tech had a
lot of machine shops and I can still
remember the first time I saw a metal
being cut and how fascinated I was by it
it was almost a magical process watching
these super hard materials being cut and
formed into usable shapes Brooklyn Tech
at that time had one CNC milling machine
it was programmed using paper tape a
strange typewriter punched little holes
in this very long skinny paper tape and
then that tape was fed into the machine
and an optical reader converted those
holes into the program the machine
resembled more a player piano than a
modern-day CNC milling machine you will
be making your name plates out of
aluminum and you will be using a modern
state-of-the-art CNC milling machine
that has a touch-sensitive liquid
crystal screen and uses modern software
but before I show you the machine and we
really delve into things I want to first
talk about cutting tools and other
things you may experience in the machine
shop so let's get started with that next
first tool I want to show you is a
simple twist drill you're all probably
familiar with this tool it has flutes
running up the sides these spiral flus
it is used in a clockwise direction to
drill a hole now before you use
the twist drill you must always start
the hole with a center drill or spot
drill now this is a double-ended spot
drill there's two drills on each side
case one breaks you can return the tool
around and use it now before you drill
with a regular drill bit you first drill
with the spot drill and you create a
small little starter hole and then you
come in with your actual drill and
complete the hole the reason for this is
it prevents walking without that hole
this drill would tend to go in perhaps
some several directions before actually
digging into the material if you need to
drill a very accurate halt you first
have to use a smaller size drill bit and
then come along with this tool which is
called a reamer the reamer is a very
precision ground tool and it will
produce a very accurate internal
diameter hole occasionally you need to
use flathead screws so that when the
screw goes into the part it's flush to
create that taper you first drill your
hole then you follow it up with this
tool which is called a countersinking
tool it's used on a drill bit on a drill
press and you come in you create the
countersink and then your screw fits
really nicely
at some point you're going to have to
create a hole that has threads in it so
that a screw can screw into it the way
this is created is you first drill with
this then you follow it up with this
tool which is called a tap the tap is
attached to a handle and the tap is used
to cut the threads
to the
ah
the next tool I want to describe to you
is a tool called in and milla this is a
flat end mill it has cutting surfaces
along the edges it has cutting surfaces
on the bottom as well it has four flutes
one two three four it spins in a
clockwise direction when it's cutting
and it is capable of cutting along the
edge across the top and in any direction
at all
notice that this particular end mill in
the center it does not have cutting
surfaces this is called a non Center
cutting end mill the end of this end
mill this part up here is called the
shank the shank of this end mill happens
to be the same diameter of the tool
itself which happens to be 3/4 of an
inch but sometimes the shank diameter
does not match the diameter of the end
all here is its baby brother
same exact thing believe it enough but
this one is only 1/16 of an inch in
diameter and here the shank you can see
is a quarter of an inch so it's a much
bigger shank than the Enloe itself this
can be used to do engraving or fine
detail work some end mills have a all
nose to them this is called a ball ended
and no or a ball nosed and when it spins
this projects a hemisphere and it allows
you to do very interesting kind of
smooth machining and surface machining
you can do a free-form shape by coming
in with a ball nose end mill some end
mills are double ended just like that
spot drill this particular end mill has
two flutes and notice that in this
particular NMO
the blades go all the way to the center
and this is called a center cutting and
Noah this end mill has the advantage of
not only being able to cut along the
sides and through but you could plunge
directly into a piece of metal with a
center cutting end mill I think you can
see the potential problem if you plunge
into a piece of aluminum with an N no
that's not center cutting when the n-no
lens starts to move there'll be that
little piece of material left in the
center which could cause you a little
bit of trouble so you can't plunge in
with a non Center cutting and mill
another tool you may encounter is
something called a fly cutter it rotates
clockwise and as it rotates it goes
across the surface of a material so if
you can kind of imagine as it rotates it
will swing along here rotating and it
will come across the surface of the
material and make it really flat okay so
we'll be using this tool as well it's a
little difficult to see how it works but
it will be obvious when you see it in
actual action okay when we machine we're
probably going to be using a coolant the
coolant provides cooling during the
cutting process and provides lubrication
it also prevents the chips from sticking
to the n-no as the cutting process will
take place so we will be definitely
using a coolant let me talk a little bit
about what they're made out of this end
mill is a silver colored end mill it
happens to be made out of a material
called HSS or high-speed steel this is
one of the most economical kind of end
mills general-purpose sort of end mills
you can purchase and it's capable of
cutting a hole many sorts of materials
mild Steel's aluminum etc but if you are
machining a very rough to machine
material difficult to machine material
like a stainless steel you may have to
move out from the high-speed tool and
into a tool made of something else
sometimes we'll encounter an end mill
that has a gold finish to it
this gold finish is actually a coating
and it's a titanium nitride coating it's
sometimes referred to in the industry is
tin but it's not tin don't confuse it
with the metal tin it's titanium nitride
gives them the to longer life and the
ability to make bigger cuts this end
mill is made out of carbide it's called
carbide micro grain this is an extremely
hard end mill and this is capable of
cutting things like stainless steel and
other super alloys this end mill is
three quarters of an inch in diameter
you can see it's fairly long gage next
to my finger and I can tell you because
this is a carbide micro grain end mill I
will bet you that this end mill costs
over $100 this high speed steel 3/4 inch
end mill perhaps costs $25 partly
because it's one not made out of the
expensive carbide but also it is it's
fairly large if it were smaller it
wouldn't be that expensive that it's
baby little brother I showed you here
this is 1/16 of an inch diameter anvil
which would be used for detailed work
this one happens to be high speed steel
so it's not going to be too expensive
probably be about $7 just to give you an
idea of what these things cost this
particularly extra-long 3/4 inch end
mill with a titanium nitride coating I
can recall is quite expensive I think
this was almost $100 as well so these
end notes can be pretty pricey let's
take a look at the way the tools get
held in the CNC milling machine here is
a typical holder used on the machine
notice it has this tapered shaft it has
a threaded threaded hole on them
it has a set screw here the end mill
notice the end mill has a flat you'll
see that flat there so this goes in like
this up with the flat and then is
tightened the allen wrench is used to
tighten the tool and that is how the
tools are typically held in the milling
machine attached to some of the tool
holders or chucks now these chucks are
used to hold drill bits so you tighten
that up by hand then you would use the
key to make the final tightness and
you've got to drill in there
occasionally you may see something like
this this is called a collet you loosen
this ring with a tool a collet opens up
and then you can pull the tool out okay
let's take a look at some of the parts
you can make on one of these CNC milling
machines now this is a gear box made
actually a prototype gearbox made for
the FIRST Robotics Competition a few
years ago these two plates are identical
you can see that it holds these circular
cutouts here were created to hold ball
bearings you can see one of them is in
place through each one of those ball
bearings would have gone a shaft and
there's a couple of years mounted on
this shaft as you can see so this
gearbox was never fully assembled but it
it had a show the ability to shift gears
a wheel got mounted in this section here
and when this gear box was fully Jeep
made it allowed the robot to move in
this direction but as far as the machine
consider a plate with a lot of hollowed
out sections and this is the kinds of
things that you're going to be able to
learn how to program using the CNC
milling machine here one here's one of
the name plates from last year this one
was created with the class in mind you
can see it has two tapped holes here and
here and it has a little bit of a radius
that goes along it and this is very
indicative of the kinds of name plates
you'll be able to make you'll be able to
make something that looks at least this
good here's one of my absolute favorite
objects that we ever made on the CNC
milling machine it's a two bladed
propeller it was made from a solid block
of balsa wood then coated with
fiberglass the way it was made let's
take a look at a poster which kind of
shows how this propeller was made the
propeller started off as a solid block
of balsa wood it was put onto a jig that
was clamped onto the table of the
milling machine the first thing that
happened was the milling machine took a
rough pass over the block of wood
creating kind of a spiral cut out into
the wood you can sort of see the
propeller beginning to come out of that
after going over the propeller and
creating a spiral staircase using a
straight in then I grabbed a ball and
started making patterns over the
propeller like that and eventually the
top surface had been smooth down there
you can see one side is a kind of smooth
it's a rough cut but it's getting close
the other side still has the spiral
staircase after the entire cutting
process was done
Paulo was taken off of the machine
flipped upside down injection phone was
put underneath the propeller to support
it for the next cut and there it is the
final so if you can imagine when the
propeller was being made a ball ended NL
came in and sort of to make paths that
look like this
because of the ball and melly here's
another interesting part this is made
out of machinable wax and this I think
represents the patella Valley and dr.
attention was working on a project
wearing they were growing cartilage
tissue in the shape of the patella and
the way they were going to grow it is
they created a mold this was the bottom
part of the mold
there was a top part of the mold and the
two pieces came together leaving a thin
little gap between the two parts and
that's where the cartilage tissue was
grown and again it was created with a
ball nose and mill and the ball as you
can kind of imagine a little hard to see
but it would come in here and it would
cut out all these strange shapes coming
in here and doing all of this rather
difficult shaping and it was eventually
made out of stainless steel this was
just a prototype which we made in
machinable wax first here's another
interesting propeller three-bladed
machined out of Wax flipped over and
eventually
these were all prototypes that led to
the making of the final propeller